i've seen everything oh come through
hustle i haven't seen kung fu hustle
[ __ ]
that's that's that's good that's a
[ __ ] banger i mean it looks [ __ ]
awesome
it's like i i to me it's like one of the
closest you could possibly get to
real life anime right it's it's
it's somehow wacky uh it's a wacky
live-action kind of slapstick well
what it does is that it it does to
parody martial arts movies yeah it just
makes a martial arts movie that is just
an anime right right yeah yeah all the
characters like i have this power
and then they do like all weird [ __ ]
spells and [ __ ] yeah yeah
so like say like the premise of this
movie is like there's like this like
axe gang right this very famous gang and
for some reason they
invade this very very small village
um that nobody's heard of and it's just
like this secret village where
coincidentally a lot of martial arts
masters have just like
it's all situated in this one city
so what happens is firstly they find
three martial arts masters who just
happened to live in the city they didn't
know they lived in the city like one
person
was just like the i think like a barber
or something or
so it's been so long yeah but
oh yeah one was the noodle store guys oh
the taylor yeah yeah
like the labourer damn you remember the
story you remember this better than me
ashley
and so after they find out these three
martial arts masters are in this
uh village they were like well we to
send assassins to assassinate them right
so they send assassins to
to like get rid of these three martial
arts masters and then it turns out
that there are even more like higher up
martial arts masters
just living in here just living in there
hierarchy hierarchy pyramid and so like
they
they just find out like more op people
just keep [ __ ] invading this village
and they keep like
more opi heroes just keep coming out of
the woodworks it's [ __ ] great
it's just literally just escalation yeah
that sounds so good it's such a funny
i've never heard of this movie
it's it's really if you watch martial
arts movies yeah which i don't like i
used to
you'll know about this just like it's
well that's the thing is like during
high school i had like a
massive like spree of just watching
every bruce lee and jack chan movie yeah
and like all the martial arts movies i
could think
same here but i never heard of this one
for some reason
yeah i mean i i feel like if you did go
through that martial arts
phase this is this is like one of the
peak of just
it's it knows the genre so well that it
kind of parodies itself right but at the
same time takes itself
100 seriously right right it's it's it's
just one of the best
i don't know that's the best kind of
movie yeah yeah yeah exactly
it does everything well for a martial
arts movie
um and that's why i love it it's got the
wacky fights and it's got like the
really well choreographed fights as well
right um but speaking of martial arts
fights
that uh defines my childhood
rush hour yeah speaking of jackie chan
there he is right there
what can you say i i wish there was more
russia
i need the dynamic i i really think that
the rush hour series was
what got me into the whole martial arts
genre
to begin with right yeah i mean honestly
maybe same i don't know it was so funny
my friend showed me when i was like
really young and i just [ __ ] fell in
love with it
it was so fun yeah yeah i mean it's it's
a like jackie chan
and chris tucker was is a dynamic that
on paper should never work they should
never have the chemistry that they do
but they have such good chemistry and
the amount of times i've rewatched
rush hour one and two especially in my
childhood is just like uncountable i
actually
don't know how much how many times i've
rewatched it because it's like
it like defined like a good like five
year period of my life because that was
what started my
martial arts phase where i just watched
so many different martial arts movies
jackie chan is very very funny yeah oh
yeah
he's one of the most charismatic actors
i feel like in that that's carried by
jackie chan
like how good he is at playing like dumb
yeah yeah yeah he's so good in this like
him playing off chris tucker it's just
yeah it's just
yeah and jackie chan is also like funny
by himself or for like a completely
different reason it's a completely clash
of styles
but like i remember when i was doing uh
during the uh
not the anime awards the trash tastes
awards when uh i was doing the uh pizza
crust i have a dream speech right
yeah people were just like wow ghan's
really uh god's really parody
martin luther king really well and i'm
just like i actually just took that
speech from rush hour too when chris
tucker did it
all of your [ __ ] uh jokes and
everything come from [ __ ] movies
yeah everything you hear on gear is just
movie questions
i mean like this is the sequel coming
out right when i'm just like these are
the movies i've rewatched so many times
that they're just ingrained in my mind
was rush hour two the best one i think
it was what what was the plot of rochard
is the paris one
no that was rush hour three that was
that was that
rush hour i love how he just immediately
knows it's like yeah that's russia
i can't remember a distinction between
any of them they're all just
all of the rush hours kind of just blend
together yeah yeah um i remember
rush hour one and two were the good ones
uh
it was three bad i don't think i think
three was average because three was kind
of like the continuous i mean i mean
jackie chan was getting like a little
bit old when rush hour three happens
so he like you could tell that he
couldn't do as many stunts as he could
do
rush hour one and two i feel like was
jackie chan more like he
he could get away with his prime was he
i don't think it was his prime but
he's definitely closer to it the back
end of his prize
i think his prime was in like 1990s
um but yeah i remember i don't know why
but i remember as a kid i
slightly preferred rush hour too i think
that was the slightly better movie but
i mean rush hour one is still [ __ ]
brilliant as well